Thank You Christian I would like to
welcome everyone I want to thank the
host committee for their time and their
effort in setting this up I want to
thank the leadership of the Columbia
University Alumni Club of France and
finally I want to thank Kristian bureaus
and Christoph knocks for their
extraordinary work in in bringing this
about this morning we have 600 alumni
and friends from 30 different countries
gathered to do what columbia university
as one of the great educational and
research institutions in the world does
best that is to think about the greatest
and highest intelligence and the
greatest commitment understanding the
most important issues of the time we
have here of course a home in in Paris
with Reid hall and that has educated
many students and faculty and served as
a base for scholarship for people all
over the world we hope very much to
build on that success and have even a
greater presence in Europe and Paris in
particular over time to frame the
discussion today I only want to say just
a very few things and then introduce the
first panel our goal is very simple at a
university at Columbia our goal is
simply to understand the world and to
try to develop ideas that will help make
it better that of course encompasses a
huge array of disciplines subjects
schools and individual work it is a
continuous conversation that goes over
decades and even centuries and we draw
on some of the greatest discoveries that
happened at Columbia that said the world
is changing radically around us and I
don't think in my life
time I have ever seen so rapid and in
many ways so positive a set of changes
these are many different there are many
different causes for this but a primary
one is the growth of economic
integration throughout the world and a
second significant cause is the growth
of interconnectedness through new
technologies like the Internet as this
happens as probably always happens but
even more so now we barely understand
what the forces are that are changing
the world at this moment we barely
understand them I think if you go at it
from any field whether it's my field law
whether it's economics or whether it's
health whether it's education whether
it's culture those of us who have spent
lifetimes trying to understand these
fields would have to say at base we
remain mystified by the great forces at
work so how this is happening what are
the implications and what might be done
to both help us understand it better and
to help shape the future are the
subjects of a great university like
Columbia and this set of panels today
we're making great efforts at Columbia
to expand our base in New York City and
all of you have probably heard about
manhattanville the great project of a
new campus that will bring six million
square feet of new space for Columbia
that's in West Harlem and by the way
this past week's are a great turning
point as the borough president and Mayor
Bloomberg strongly endorsed the entire
project and we now go to the City
Planning Commission where we also hope
very much for a positive outcome this
next week this will end at the end of
this semester
or less into January in the City Council
and then we will be on our way this
offers us for the first time in a
hundred years the chance to expand
Columbia and physically and that
expansion in a physical sense will
enable us we hope to reach out more to
the world beyond us we have a number of
panels today that I just feel extremely
fortunate to be here to listen to I
think we all will feel incredibly
grateful at the end of the day we begin
with the issue of media something very
dear to my heart and something that I
would like less of frankly but I really
am happy to talk about it and listen to
people talk about it and there's no one
better to lead that discussion than our
amazing Dean of the School of Journalism
Nick lemon then we have a new dean whom
gene and I hosted for a reception just
the week ago Carol Becker and the only
thing that I could think of to say was
I'm not sure Columbia is ready for Carol
Becker and you'll see why when she
interviews our wonderful new colleague
at Columbia Ohan Tomic knows Nobel
prize-winning author of course in the
afternoon it's my privilege to take the
temperature of some of our greatest
faculty members who focus on
globalization particularly from a
development economic and social
environmental development standpoint
also educational standpoint and we have
Susan Furman who's our new and very
dynamic and committed Dean sorry
president of Teachers College our Nobel
prize-winning economists Joe Stiglitz
and our tireless and eminent
and extremely and justifiably well-known
director of the Earth Institute Jeffrey
Sachs that will be followed by a keynote
address by Kofi Annan who I just admired
tremendously and I think that admiration
is shared throughout this room the
importance of people from a variety of
positions in life speaking out in their
own voice who the moral conscience of
the world and the social conscience of
the world the policy conscience of the
world is exceedingly important and I can
think of no secretary-general of the UN
who has matched Kofi Annan in that and
he's a dear dear friend of Columbia and
we look forward to a long relationship
with Kofi Annan and he will be here to
speak to us this evening we will close
with a dinner that should be an
opportunity to have fun and to enjoy it
but also to carry on the conversations
that have been sparked by today so I
look forward to this I now turned this
over i believe to to nick lemon is that
correct and thank you for being here
we're delighted to be here